in the Rolling Hills of Kentucky a
mystery has the horse racing World
spinning
[Applause]
heading up to the prestigious Kentucky
Derby at Churchill Downs Racetrack five
horses were put down after training or
racing incident
[Applause]
as after being injured on Derby Day
itself
an eight died in another race there this
week three more died at neighboring
keenland race track this month
around 1.25 horses die for every 1 000
horses that start an American race but
the Kentucky deaths mark an unusually
large cluster in a short time whenever
we see clusters of injuries it's a
natural thing to you know believe there
could be either a common common thread
with the surface or some other issue
clusters Are Not Unusual the timing
around the Derby is many injured horses
can be saved through surgery but when
thoroughbreds weighing more than 500
Kilograms travel at speeds topping 65
kilometers per hour the injuries are
often unrecoverable so what killed so
many horses in May some in the racing
World believe it was a combination of
factors it's bred worn out for Speed
instead of stamina so the the breed
itself is not quite as strong it may be
more susceptible to breakdowns also the
amount of drugs that are used in the in
the sport
in Thoroughbred country where
century-old breeding farms raise future
Champions there is fear for a business
that also Fosters Kentucky Pride joy and
a way of life
for many here in Lexington horse racing
isn't just an industry it's a lifestyle
and anything that affects it affects
them
at Mill Ridge Farm which bred Kentucky
Derby winners Barbaro and Street sense
and raised a third Giacomo heedley Bell
is the fifth generation owner it's very
painful because
we love the horse we're all about the
horse
when you drive around and when you walk
the fields of of Mill Ridge and the
other 500 farms in this community
you get a feel for the passion that we
have
at the track and in the barns of
Kentucky ending worries over a spike in
equine fatalities is crucial to
preserving a tradition John hendren Al
Jazeera Lexington Kentucky
foreign